the Joe Rogan experience it's um
I think it's an interesting time for
people to communicate though I don't
think anybody has ever really gotten to
the bottom of things in later I mean in
in in the past the way people are trying
to get to the bottom of things now
there's a lot of noise
what do you mean emotionally I think
emotionally the way we communicate with
each other even the way people are
examining government and and examining
foreign policy and examining the Office
of the President and examining voting
and the electoral process and there's
there's things that people are in
analyzing now and looking at that I
think because of all the the chaos of
the internet we kind of lose sight of
all the crazy [ __ ] that it's doing like
it's doing so many different things and
changing things so much that it's it's
rewiring the way people are looking at
the world itself yeah and that's why all
these [ __ ] drugs are getting
legalized the a giant part of why
psilocybin is getting legalized now it's
decriminalized in Denver
marijuana's being decriminalized left
and right it's because people here
people like you and me and anyone else
that has a brain that understands about
drug laws here I'm talking about it and
you go this is correct you can't lock
people up for mushrooms and you should
take them yeah she [ __ ] take them
they probably fix your brain they
probably give you a new perspective and
make you realize you were being a dick
it's half of what's wrong with us right
we're just worried about how we
interface with each other you're saying
the Internet is giving people insights
and information that's changing the way
we live I think so for sure I think the
access to information because the stream
is so large so much nonsense comes
through it that you you lose perspective
of all the positive changes taking place
because the internet right all these
drug legalization things I don't think
would ever be possible without all of
the information that's been distributed
online whether it's through videos or
through people talking about or podcasts
or comedy routines or just facts with
facts based you know news organizations
start putting the here's the real facts
about marijuana and you know and
fatalities and
this is this is these are the real facts
about where their eyes going how it's
going right now to fund cartels and how
this is crazy because we're literally
creating an organized crime Empire
because we're making something that
everybody wants Yeah right all that
stuff is available now you can't rush to
shots we were just talking about that's
another one I can't squash it with
propaganda yeah like they could in the
pad that you just kind of decide what
narrative gets played out in the
newspaper right you can't do that
anymore well did you read that article I
sent you about stories versus facts yes
I did and it's the you know I'd you've
all haughty right yes the guy that wrote
sapiens and it basically says that you
know stories Trump facts and that
basically we are a culture the human the
human species has always believed the
myth whether it's religion or whether
it's a political Dogma that we are more
apt to ignore facts that don't support a
story because telling facts being
factual is difficult because sometimes
that fact doesn't jibe with what you
thought was true and now you have to
rectify that and that's hard and so it's
easier for us to just say you know we're
all Jesus came and when we die our sins
will be forgiven and we're supposed to
do this and then if facts come up to
negate how how long ago man you know all
that all the things we know from
archeology that negate everything that's
in the Bible then the story you still
have 60% of the of our country doesn't
believe that the they think the planet
is 6,000 years old
I think it's 46% yeah yeah 46% of the
country thinks that but they only think
of it in terms of they won't denounce
the Bible do they really I mean if you
had a gun to their head they really
think that I don't think it's that high
I think it's a lot of horseshit yeah I
think there's a lot of people that say
if that's what the Bible says so is that
what the Bible says most the Bible says
believe this tale and Burt I told him
that's what the Bible says mama good boy
yeah there's a lot of that right when
he's with his friends he cracks open a
beer he's like what the [ __ ] does my
mama know
[ __ ] at this old she is yes trend now
a lot of people go to church on Sunday
because culturally that's what you do
yeah it doesn't mean they subscribe to
all that stuff but then you got you know
the every four years the government puts
out an environmental study that is done
by I think twelve different departments
in the government and it's considered
the quintessential update on where the
environment is internationally yeah and
that came out in November and it was
damning about pollutants and the
administration put it out on Black
Friday the day after Thanksgiving at
three o'clock in the morning and they
buried it and in it is everything about
global warming you ever needed to know
and they're no longer calling it global
warming they're no longer calling it's
no longer fossil fuel it's freedom what
is the new thing they're calling it
freedom juice something like that Jesus
come they're literally changing the name
of fossil fuels this is the Trump
administration yeah yes natural gas is
being rebranded to freedom gas wow this
is like some Team America world police
type [ __ ] and it's like people the one
deny global warming it's like the facts
are there in refute I don't think
anyone's denying that the planets
warming right I think they're denying
how much of an impact human beings have
and whether or not it's worth changing
the way we do in industry ya know and
whether or not we're need to impose more
restrictions on on exhaust fumes and I
mean factories how much your drive drive
by a factory you see that pillowing
smoke and you're like how the [ __ ] are
we allowing that yeah like there's
places to this day where you drive there
and you go oh this group gets to pollute
the air that the babies breathe yeah
they do for this business whatever the
[ __ ] they're doing what are they making
tires they get to pollute the air yeah
what is the worst polluter like when you
drive by a factory you see the the black
smoke shooting in this guy what the [ __ ]
are they doing
cruise ships I think I read they're the
number one a polluter we did a thing
where we were trying to figure out was
it with who was it with
someone was explaining how much
devastation cruise ships do in terms of
the amount of fuel that they burn and
the impact that they have and the fact
those Valentin Thomas was at her they
were talking about how like each cruise
ship like how much actual fuel they burn
off it's preposterous
I think I read they're the biggest
burners of fossil fuels in the world so
a giant [ __ ] metal thing in the water
yeah you ever try to push a [ __ ]
rowboat
it's a lot of work it's a lot of work
how what [ __ ] are people where they
built something like the Titanic like
just what kind of an [ __ ] says not
only am I gonna make it out of metal
look can we just use a bunch of small
boats and get me nope nope no no I'm
gonna make the biggest biggest boat ever
and when I write on it even God can't
sink it
I mean I'm Noah imagine what an [ __ ]
you have to be to write even God can't
shake it
yeah on the side of the boat oh is that
what they wrote yes oh that's hilarious
isn't that is that that's a fact right
God that better not be an urban myth I
think it said on the side of the Titanic
even God can't sink it yeah yeah
they weren't one of these people to be
excited and they're going nowhere
cruise ship just going nowhere well it
was something to do back then yeah
imagine living back then
oh I don't know antenna quit auditioning
how that was a TV yeah was a Titanic
1920s yeah the roaring the remaking one
and setting out to tank to name didn't
did it say what I think it's hood that's
a quote someone said an employee I don't
know if it was written off it was
written more than 1911 oh it's a launch
coat it was 1911 quote rather 1911 [ __ ]
live and then it's more than a hundred
years ago okay I hate people were they
back then we went so what kind of
Cave people with a back then yeah do you
have x-ray machines how the [ __ ] they
sit your broken leg what they do
yeah well the other thing on the cruise
ships it's a video about how much they
pollute whoa one ship or watch a cruise
ship pollute as much as 13 million cars
in one day is what this video is called
Wow
no [ __ ] whoa paulie's got some one's
bigger over to overtime holy Sh million
cars well let's just ban cruise ships
Trump to zero Trump cruise ship
why doesn't he have a cruise only
because he hasn't thought of it yeah
he's gonna hear this podcast haha